and we have liftoff at 13 exactly fifty
years ago today NASA launched the Apollo
13 mission into space it was supposed to
be a third mission to land humans on the
moon but two days after launch an
explosion in the spacecraft's oxygen
system put the three-man crew in mortal
danger thanks to their quick thinking
and the ingenuity of NASA's scientists
the astronauts returned to earth safely
an investigation was launched
immediately after one member of the
panel looking at what went wrong was
Neil Armstrong the first man to set foot
on the moon Armstrong spent most of his
life after his moonwalk shunning
attention but he still took the time to
respond to some of the tens of thousands
of letters he received in the years
afterward some of those interactions are
compiled in a new book dear Neil
Armstrong and they reveal a lot about
Armstrong and ourselves one thing that's
really great about about these letters
is that you never really know what
you're going to find Jim Henson is Neil
Armstrong's official biographer he wrote
the book first man we need to fail down
here so we don't fail up there and
consulted on the movie that followed and
the appeared stayed a test pilot he
would have continued to contribute in a
cheap Hanson's latest project going
through a vast treasure trove of letters
the new book he put together
dear Neil Armstrong was released this
past fall before that happened we got an
early look at the source material it's
kept at Purdue alma mater of more
astronauts than any University including
Armstrong this storage room is not open
to the public
Tracy grim is the curator how many
correspondents are we talking about here
there's at least 70,000 pieces of paper
in just the fan mail section alone the
rest of this 450 some boxes are the rest
of Neil's life really he's in these
boxes he really is Oh
working with Grimm Hansen separated the
letters into categories but there is one
prevailing theme most of these letters
are not people giving him something it's
them asking him for something
yeah they ask him for everything I mean
autographs pictures you know there's one
woman in Italy asks for one of his socks
really it's kind of like holding up a
mirror to ourselves to our culture here
he had become this global icon stepping
onto another world first person to do
that some people thought he was like a
demigod that he had insights into the
universe that nobody else had and they
wanted him to share those secrets you
know never one to overstate his
accomplishments or claim more knowledge
than he had Armstrong didn't always
respond but sometimes he did like when
an environmentalist from Philadelphia
accused him of polluting the solar
system so this is someone writing saying
they're upset that they left things
behind on the moon mr. Nickerson here is
concerned about environmental
degradation and trash I'm strong sent a
long letter back and as you can see from
the second paragraph NASA has taken all
reasonable precautions to avoid
disrupting the natural environment of
the moon there's a merchant in Turkey
who Armstrong paid for souvenirs in 1970
this is a guy living in Turkey who sold
Neil Armstrong something when he was
there visiting didn't want to cash the
check because it was from Neil Armstrong
but then wrote Neil Armstrong to say can
you send me another cheque
so what Neil did is he sent a duplicate
check and he says keep either one for
yourself and cash the other and enclosed
as a photograph which we may find
preferable to the cheque in which case
you may feel free to destroy the second
check the volume of international
letters surprised Hansen specifically
the many complimentary letters from our
Cold War nemesis and one of the first
chapters you deal with is letters from
Soviets from Russia yeah who were
congratulating him that's right one
reason I wanted to do that chapter is
that there was kind of this idea that
the Soviets paid no attention to Apollo
11 and didn't believe it some of them
didn't or that there was no news of
Apollo 11s moon-landing for Soviet
citizens to even know about but
in the Armstrong correspondence you see
a lot of letters from not just Soviet
citizens but from the Eastern Bloc
countries and they were all not none of
them were nasty there are also many
letters from kids some sweet like this
dinner invitation from a young girl some
heartbreaking including a 14 year old
looking for an autograph his mother
attached a separate letter telling
Armstrong the boy didn't know it but was
terminally ill Armstrong whose daughter
died of cancer at just 2 wrote back
immediately
Douglas wrote you that hearing from you
would be the happiest moment of his life
perhaps it was just 2 hours after your
letter arrived he fell sweetly and
peacefully asleep with the sweetest
little smile on his face not to awaken
again on this earth somewhere you have a
new little guardian angel who joins me
in these sentiments I'm not sure there's
a letter that's more poignant and than
that one man that moment still gets me
Michelle I think it's important that
means you write in these extraordinarily
challenging times we have accomplished
extraordinary things before yes was so
little and it's gumption that got us
there and I do believe gumption will get
us there again that stick-to-itiveness
determination Neil Armstrong certainly
had it he reached for the stars no doubt
thank you Jeff